on the mound for the blue jays making
his 26th start and he's pitching on an
extra day's rest so that's always been
good for ryu you look at his numbers for
the season of 411 earned run average
annie janssen trying to get the sign
as it now and he got him to chase down
and in one down
third baseman number 20 josh donaldson
[Applause]
pretty cool had some great years for the
blue jays of course including winning
the american league mvp award
a one-hopper up the middle backhanded by
simeon and it's a nice three-up
three-down inning for hyunjin ryu blue
jays coming up bottom of the first
michael pineda
auditioning for the league but also for
the twins but you should be able to
handle this moment in this good
offensive team
and springer goes after the first pitch
skies it to center field buxton's there
one away
and a pop-up short right center field
kepler coming in
and it's buxton calling him off at the
very last second a hitless scoreless
first on to the second no score
miguel
he's faced ryu three times he's one for
three as the 3-2 to cenote misses in
ball four nice job miguel cino a lead
off walk
swinging a miss arise as we mentioned
doesn't strike out often but ryu gets
him as brent rooker awaits the last
at-bat for rooker before the birth of
his daughter blair
was a two-run two-out double
rooker to the gap left center field it's
down for a hit and that will score a run
dickerson cuts it off and cenote is in
scoring with rooker in at second base
with a double a couple weeks ago the
birth of his daughter hit a home run in
that game here rooker takes a change up
it looks like off the plate you see him
turn it over coming out of the hand he's
interested you know ricker's numbers
don't jump off the page but he hits
lefty as well one nothing minnesota we
go to the home second for t oscar
hernandez corey dickerson and lourdes
gorilla jr
and a fast ball up and away gets a swing
in a minute jump one to nothing in the
bottom of the second and a michael
pineda will face a guy now who has had a
lot of success against him and that is
corey dickerson
and that's gonna find a hole into right
center field dickerson with a base head
now heading to second and in there
safely and that'll bring up yet another
blue jay hitter who is hot right now
danny jansen
it short by polanco double clenched a
bit high throw
sails over the bag and a run's going to
come in to score
as jake lamb comes up
now
three errors in short lamb lines one
into left center diving effort by ref
snyder but this one gets to the fence
jansen around third and into score
and the throw now gets away and lamb
will come to third
another run
another error two to one blue jays a
good pitch to get chance to hit into a
ground ball
and then they just throw it around this
is going to be a double for
lamb as ref snyder dives for it it goes
beyond him up against the fence chance
is going to score easily on the play and
then the throw from the relay man not
even close to the catcher will be
jeffers buxton and polanco as the 1-1
delivered and grounded back up the
middle and that's a base hit jeffers has
had a couple of nice games of late he
picks up the second hit of the night for
the twins lead off man on for buxton and
now buxton mentioned that byron's in a
bit of a strikeout rut see if he can put
the ball in play here
there's a high fly to left
and
off the wall
and jeffers around third he's going to
be waved around he'll score with a
misplay in the gap
and now polanco with the go ahead run at
third
and a high fly to left center
hit deep back and gone a two-run home
run for jory polanco and the twins jump
out in front four to two well he hit 106
miles an hour his first time up with
nothing to show for it here he gets
himself a hanging breaking ball crushes
it
104 miles an hour ovation for josh
donaldson as he comes to the plate for
the second time
lifted to right and deep hernandez is
back he's at the wall and that one's
gone
josh donaldson hitting his 23rd of the
year
and the twins strike for four quick runs
in the third well it sounded good
he's hit enough in that ballpark to know
whether they're going to go or not in
that ball an opposite field shot montoya
lifts the baseball strippling is
summoned and we've got a pitching change
early tonight in toronto and for a long
time
ross stripling was in the rotation of
course and pitching very well before he
was sidelined and now it looks like
stripling is going to get an extended
relief outing here as ceno digs in again
nobody out four runs in on four hits
already in the inning
and now sono unloads straight away
center field back to back to back
another solo home run for ceno his 29th
of the year a no doubt blast to
straightaway center field i'm sure this
is what the blue jays had ideas of doing
to the twins when they saw them coming
in with a struggling record not having a
great year as a team but you know what
they've been able to do this all year
they've been able to drive the ball to
the ballpark and snow this thing hit off
the facing i believe the second deck
there in toronto straight away center
field here comes guerrero he walked in
the first inning working quickly
guerrero rips it to left field number 46
for vlady boy he was all over that one
and a typical vlady get out of here in a
heartbeat kind of home run you can see
this coming in his first hit back when
he walked against pineda he wasn't
fooled by anything he threw him of his
46 home runs he has now tied joe
dimaggio's 1937 mark and trails only
eddie matthews from 1953 he hit 47.
buxton struck out of the first and had
an rbi double in the third
he drives this one to left field and a
nice catch made by goriel
on the warning track and looks like he's
okay good play by lourdes for round
number two took a good route to the ball
and it makes makes a good catch
merryweather will face rooker kepler and
jeffers in the twin sixth he's on that
artificials that synthetic turf
balls hit high in the air right field
and hit well and this ball's got a
chance and gone an opposite field home
run for brent rooker
there's his eighth of the year an
opposite field blast
and coleman in a non-save situation
bouncer easy play
polanco fires and the twins impressively
win the opener in toronto seven to three
and now they've won eight straight games
at the rogers center
you